this program is brought to you by Emory
University a teacher is like a candle
which lights others and consuming itself
today it is my pleasure to introduce to
you one such professor who is bright in
many lives dr. manish Tripathi as a
recipient of the distinguished educator
award dr. chapati has been an extremely
influential person in my life and I'm
very fortunate to have had him as my
first marketing professor at goizueta
and to have him today as a mentor and a
friend I first met dr. Tripathi about
when it enrolled in his class about two
and a half years ago it just so happened
I was new to the course and he was new
to the field of teaching since he was
new to the school we had no idea what to
expect from his classes we couldn't log
on to learn link and look up class
comments so with fear we entered his
first lecture but were welcomed with
this charming charisma after all he is a
marketing professor and he was able to
market himself very well to the student
body his class lectures were always
highly energetic full of stimulating
examples and mind-boggling questions he
has the ability to relate complicated
concepts such as customer lifetime value
to everyday phenomena dr. Tripathi is a
truly amazing an innovative teacher he
has an innate ability to inspire and
motivate but what sets him apart is the
way he genuinely lives his life one of
my fondest memories from his class would
be during it was Valentine's Day and I
clearly remember he ordered flowers from
calyx flowers calm to show an example of
how retailers have different attributes
that they market and provide they
provide two different demands in the
market and I believe Caylee's flowers
come obviously did an amazing job
marketing as they obviously caught dr.
tripathi's attention and he ordered on
40 so as you can see dr. chapati has
always and always is always looking for
ways to make learning more fun and
interactive and as I shall say
most of us will always remember the
concepts and frameworks that he taught
us in class so Edison once said what
sculpture is to block of a marble
education is to the soul I can say that
dr. manish Tripathi is an excellent
sculpture sculptor who's ingenious and
diligent effort has made a brilliant
career so it is a privilege to be here
trying to use dr. Manish Tripathi as the
distinguished educator award of 2011 and
to repeat a statement I always make dr.
Tripathi has had a perm has made a
permanent impact on my life and if in my
life if I manage to profoundly affect as
many people as i watch dr. Tripathi
effect in a single semester I will
consider it a life well-lived so please
join me in congratulating dr. Manish
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University